[موسيقى]
من دخلت الاكاديميه الفنون كنت انا حاب
ادخل رسم لكن اساتذتي من شافوا شغلي
بالنحت قالوا لي معتصم ادخل على النحت
وراح تنطلق اكثر وتبدا اكثر من رسم
الاثناء الحرب انا كنت اتجول في بغداد في
كل الطلقات كنت تزور المناطق اللي تتعرض
للقصف وشاهد مدى الدمار اللي تعرض لولادي
من جراء هذه الحرب
[موسيقى]
كنت مجموعه من طلبتي في معهد الفنون في
بغداد وانا بدخل للمعهد
صاد الحادث الاجرامي ودخلت احدى الشظايا
من
المتفجر في رجلي وما تزال حقيقه اعاني من
هذا الموضوع بالرغم من موضوع حوالي 8
سنوات او تسع سنوات
افكار القويه تحتاج الى خامه قويه طبعا
وما في اجمل او اقوى من خامه البرونز اللي
هي قادره على نقل ادق المشاعر الانسانيه
انا حاولت انه اوظف اللون في خدمه الفكره
وفي خدمه العمل كل عمل هو يعكس حاله معينه
قد اكون شفتها في منطقتنا العربيه العسكر
اللي مدخومين
بالثماله بالاجرام بالكره
من كل فنان رساله فنيه او جماليه او فكريه
لكن لا غير من انه توجد مساحه
واسعه الى انتماء الوطني
وهويته الشخصيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات